some bite size questions that i'm gonna
answer hit me with those
cues we have some of my favorite bite
size questions this week by the way
i'm jealous are you answering these big
eyebrow i feel you bro
uh on twitter at captain brow you really
underline this
uh how big how big
would steve rogers be if he started out
with the height
and body structure of dwayne
the rock johnson before he gets the
super soldier serum how big would he get
so there's a couple ways to answer this
amazing question
so in captain america the winner soldier
he goes to the captain america museum
and they actually give us some numbers
they show that skinny steve
played by landordini the body double in
the first movie was
5'3 and weighed 95 pounds before the
serum
the transformation into buff steve led
to him being
six feet tall and 240 pounds after the
serum
that would mean a 14 increase in height
and a 153 increase in weight which makes
sense the taller you get you get a lot
heavier for every inch
yeah yeah you grow out you grow out more
than you grow
up right lucky so let's look at the
rocks numbers the rox numbers are
reported as
he's 6'5 and he weighs 260 pounds
so with those same size increases
if you were to just apply the same
numerical increases that skinny steve
got uh
the rock would be seven three and
that's a lot of mass so just to give you
some context that's two inches taller
than shaq
but double shaq's weight in theory steve
rogers incredible growth was actually
the result of him
already being weak and skinny to begin
with and that weakness made him more
appreciative of strength
he made him more heroic and more brave
because he had to go into a lot of
fights knowing he would lose
and it's those qualities that amplify
the serum according to dr erskine
so theoretically if steve began with the
body of the rock he probably
wouldn't have lost as many fights he
probably would be
a bit prouder more aggressive more vain
about his body
so he wouldn't have those inner
qualities that caused the growth to be
so expansive
we know it was the same kind of serum
that blonsky
took to become abomination in the hulk
movies and he didn't get bigger he just
got more aggressive
and then he took this diluted version of
banner's blood to become abomination
so like you know just not to talk too
much about the dwayne johnson because
he's he's a great guy
he cares about his fans and dwayne i've
always liked you so eric is the one that
you should be mad at
he's a great guy i want to hang out with
him but he also refuses to lose a fight
in
any of his movies eric how did you
manage to angle this question into
sharing your beef with the rock you use
the rocket scene example
he seems like an all right guy i'm just
saying like
bodybuilders who have spent their entire
lives crafting their bodies to look that
way and to get huge
don't want to think about like losing
fights
they're coming back from other things
where they grew up like losing fights or
getting beat down they
needed some kind of motivation so i
don't think they're thinking about like
how much more can i improve on this
you don't think the rock grew up getting
his ass kicked have you seen the 90s
picture of the rock
he was a big guy but he was well he's
from miami he's probably getting in some
fights you're from miami you know how
violent that place can be i've died
every time i've gone to miami but before
i continue thanks to our friends at bang
energy for sponsoring this video
every can of bang energy has zero
calories zero carbs zero sugar
zero artificial colors each 16 ounce can
contains 300 milligrams of caffeine
super creo teen coq10 and bcaas
i am sipping on black cherry vanilla
it's like i have now found the only soda
flavor i want for the rest of my life i
drink a bang when i need to pick me up
in the morning or when i just need to
plow through a long video and i want my
mind to be alert which i know you guys
need it to be check out bang on
instagram get 25
off your order at bang energy.com when
you use the code newrockstars25
there you can buy a variety pack of bang
energy or a whole pack of just your
favorite flavor
editor john loves radical skedaddle and
off-screen producer zack drinks their
sweet tea
flavor whereas i am team black cherry
vanilla thanks again to bang energy for
sponsoring this video get 25
off your order at bang energy.com using
the code newrockstars25
this one comes from uh ryan thomas at
time for eats
theoretically
[Music]
can hulk throw a bowling ball
at the moon and hit it and if so
what kind of damage he gonna do to the
moon if the moon was made of
spear ribs would you throw a bowling
ball
at it it started as bill cosby and then
i remember that wasn't cozy that was
harry carey harry carey i shared this
one on twitter
and it was like one of my favorite
threads i got a lot of research
and uh science help from robert and
scott and ray
and chris you guys are great many others
okay so here's what we were able to
figure out earth's escape velocity
is 11.186 kilometers per second or
kilometers per second
so just to explain escape velocity it's
a velocity at which the sum of an
object's kinetic energy
and gravitational potential energy is
zero it allows you to escape
the earth's orbit and you can break
earth's gravity and drift off into space
towards things like the moon the problem
is
if hulk for whatever reason he would
want to throw a bowling ball at the moon
say
mad at it that 7 10 split or yeah the
bowling ball is just
the thing within his grasp unlike a
lunar rocket a bowling ball doesn't have
like an
ongoing force emitted from a rocket
booster that allows it to continue
propelling and propelling it would need
all of its force to break that orbit
in hulk's initial throw also you run
into the problem that the bowling ball
is made of a material that would
probably melt
when it was going through the atmosphere
due to the heat and the friction uh
but it would depend on whether that
bowling ball's core is either made out
of iron oxide as many of them are
or ceramic because some bowling balls
apparently have ceramic cores
if it's ceramic it could survive that
heat because it has a higher melting
point
which is why your toilet bowl survives
your heat that's right i sit on it for
hours and the friction
the lava flow so there was an article
written for
wired by rhett elaine and he did the
math on how hard
superman would have to uppercut
someone's head to send them into space
so it's kind of comparable because the
human head weighs eight pounds we
learned that from
jerry maguire and uh in in many bowling
balls at least a light bowling ball
is eight pounds most of them are heavier
than that but let's use that as an
example
his math because he did lots of math
using the air resistance
using heat using uh trajectory all that
stuff
4.2 trillion newtons in order to
overcome earth's gravity to hit escape
velocity at the point it would need to
break earth's orbit
okay so if hulk throws the ball with
that force
accounting for air resistance even
atmospheric theoretically the bowling
ball could escape
earth's orbit but hulk would also have
to calculate trajectory because he's
aiming for the moon he's not just trying
to get out of space
so based off of where he is on the earth
he would have to basically
curve the ball uh at that exact angle in
order to strike the moon because it's a
small target
i used to have a video game where
monkeys threw bananas at buildings
do you remember that and you had to put
in the angle and the force
it's the same thing phillip uh now
just to answer the other part of the
question what would it do to the moon at
that point
just by escaping earth's uh gravity the
baldness wouldn't necessarily be moving
at like
a super strong speed or momentum so it
would probably just hit the moon
make like a meteorite style crater in it
uh unless we're talking the comics like
world breaker mode
hulk where he can smash planets but
that's like
a comics version of the hulk that's
completely ignoring physics and it's not
even worth having so the moon survives
all that
yeah at that point when you when you uh
send like a lunar rocket to the moon it
doesn't smash the moon
and that has way bigger mass are usually
smash the moon have you seen the footage
of when they landed on the moon
they did have reverse thrusters but like
yeah they
that's when they were trying to land men
on the moon but they they definitely
shot stuff at the moon
and uh and it doesn't blow up the moon
we're lucky the moon
hasn't tried to hit us back by the way
you know the moon was created from like
probably a comet or something hitting
earth and then spit it out into the moon
well folks that is our show now a
reminder you can join our official
discord by becoming a patron at
patreon.comrockstars and you can submit
questions to us that way
we usually see those before we see
anything else you'll try to send us
uh you can also get an audio version of
the show by subscribing to new rockstars
big question wherever
you get your podcasts and uh yeah thanks
to everyone who submitted questions some
really good questions this week this is
fun
a lot of math and you can send us your
big questions on twitter of course using
the hashtag bigquestion or
mail us at rpo box listed here you
follow me at eavos follow philip
philip molina and follow new rockstars
on all socials and subscribe here on
youtube to get too much information
about the stuff you care about
see you next week stay safe stay healthy
see ya
[Music]
you